l'heure est venue de mettre fin à la
plus longue guerre de l'amérique
ce sont les mots de job hayden ce
mercredi le président américain s'est
exprimé sur le retrait de ses troupes
sur le sol afghan d'ici au 11 septembre
après vingt ans de guerre le président
américain souhaite rapatrier ses hommes
et mettre un terme à la présence
militaire en afghanistan
il a remplacé la date butoir
initialement fixé par son prédécesseur
donald trump et les talibans au 1er mai
afin de laisser quatre mois
supplémentaires aux forces américaines
et ainsi opérer un retrait ordonné un
non respect de l'accord fixé en février
2020 qui ne convient pas aux talibans si
l'accord est violée et les forces
étrangères ne quitte pas notre pays à la
date prévue
il y aura sûrement des problèmes et ceux
qui ne respectent pas l'accord seront
tenus pour responsables malgré cet
accord entre américains et talibans
signé en février 2020 à doha au qatar
la violence demeure à un niveau très
élevé sur le terrain entre insurgés et
forces afghanes
des négociations qui devaient être
relancé par la conférence sur la paix en
afghanistan
organisée sous l'égide de l'onu à
istanbul du 24 avril au 4 mai prochain
mais ce mardi les talibans ont prévenu
qu'il refuserait d'y participer tant que
les troupes américaines n'auront pas
quitté le territoire afghan
quant à la russie elle a estimé ce
mercredi qu'en revenant sur l'accord
washington risquait de provoquer une
escalade de violence en asie centrale
cela soulève l'inquiétude une possible
escalade du conflit armé en afghanistan
qui à son tour pourrait saper les
efforts du lancement des négociations
inter afghane dans ce contexte nous
répétons notre souhait de préserver un
dialogue constructif entre les parties
s'affrontent en afghanistan et pour
mener à la fin de ce long conflit
si les états unis
compte plus que 2500 soldats sur place
la mission résolu tso porte de l'otan
implique au total neuf 1600 militaires à
la date anniversaire du 11 septembre
les troupes des pays de l'alliance
atlantique quitteront elle aussi la
piste